The answer is that L is recognizable.
A machine that recognizes
L is fairly simple.
It just feeds the input 100010 into
M and then accepts after M halts.
If M loops, so then so
will this machine.
If it doesn't loop,
then this machine will accept.
Note that it's not clear if it's
possible to recognize the complement.
If you haven't taken a class on
the theory of computation before,
then you might think it possible that
there are only some dozens or hundreds
of ways that infinite loops occur, and
that you could check all of those cases.
This is at least unclear,
and as we'll see later,
it actually turns out to be false.
Simulation defer this recognized in
this language doesn't work either.
We can't just run the machine and
wait until it doesn't halt.
That doesn't make any sense.
Another possible idea is
to monitor the machine
by keeping track of every
configuration it has been in, and
if it ever repeats a configuration,
to declare that it doesn't halt.
This might detect some
non halting behavior, but
because a Turing machine's
tape is infinite,
it can run forever without actually
ever repeating a configuration.
Students will sometimes object that
this strategy of monitoring for
loops would work on any
computer with finite memory.
The trouble is that it would require
more memory than the machine being
monitored would have access to.
So the monitor would have to be
a different computational model
than the machine it's monitoring.
As a practical method
of detecting cycles,
this strategy doesn't work either.
Consider the fact that a computer with a
gigabyte of RAM has over 8 billion bits
and therefore over two to the 8
billion possible configurations.
That's a lot of possible configurations
before you detect a cycle.
The bottom line is that this objection
isn't satisfactory, either in theory or
in practice.
Monitoring and looking for cycles of
configurations just doesn't cut it.